this is china's gateway to europe the
container terminal in pereas greece in
2009 the beijing-based shipping company
costco began leasing the struggling port
and turned it into one of the largest
terminals outside of asia
costco is expanding the facilities and
bidding for the state's 67 percent stake
in the port some consider china's
presence a hostile takeover
but tasos van vakidis commercial manager
of costco subsidiary pct sees no cause
for concern
we want to do our best
we want to establish as a better
international port
because greece's geographical location
is ideal
that will also help improve the
country's economy
critics say the success has been at the
expense of employees who've had to
endure pay cuts and increase output
employee giorgos anadiades disagrees
the work is much better than i expected
at least we're paid on time
and it's more than people are in
elsewhere
a few kilometers to the east is the
former athens airport the grounds are
three times the size of monaco and
unused since 2004.
now a multinational greek-led consortium
is planning to build a town with a
casino apartments and a public park for
7 billion euros
i believe
we a lot of effort has been made in the
last two years to make the country more
attractive to international capital and
i hope we're gonna move towards this
direction
but if a left-leaning government wins a
snap election that could hamper
privatization efforts
airport operator frapport recently was
selected for a concession to manage 14
regional airports in greece including
hanya in crete
last summer 2 million passengers passed
through the airport
next year even more tourists are
expected
local business leaders say it's a
mistake if locals aren't involved in the
projects
we're worried
we think privatizations are not good for
us
many people share this view job security
is a leading concern currently eu funds
are being used to expand the airport
next summer frapport wants to take over
as long as its plans aren't disrupted by
a change in government
you